ALEX MOHR: Welcome, everyone.
Thank you for coming
to Building For Trust.
Hope you're enjoying
the last few hours
of GCP Next this year.
My co-presenter,
Jess Frazelle, and I
are going to talk about how to
run containers securely using
Google Container Engine.
So before I introduce her
and she introduces me,
I thought I've mention
the context that we're
going to assume you have.
If this is your first time
hearing about Kubernetes
and you don't know
about containers,
this talk may be a little
too high-level for you.
You can either find something
else to go listen to
or just follow along
as best you can.
So we are going to assume you
have general knowledge of some
of these things.
My co-presenter here
is Jess Frazelle.
She's on the Google Container
Engine security team
and also works on Kubernetes.
She recently drove a lot
of the process improvements
for doing security
vulnerabilities and disclosure
and patching that.
Before she joined Google, she
was working on Docker itself
and was involved in a lot of the
Linux security module support
in that system.
Jess.
JESSICA FRAZELLE: I'll
introduce Alex Mohr, my coworker
and the technical
team and manager
of some of the Google
Container Engine teams,
including Platform Security.
For two and a half years,
he's worked on GKE.
And then before that, he worked
on the Google Compute Engine.
So what we're going
to cover today
as a basic outline is security
boundaries, identity and access
management, runtime
security in a demo,
and then the Kubernetes
roadmap for the future.
So let's just dive right
into the security boundaries.
We have these various
security models.
The way it works today
is a single tenant.
There is one trust boundary,
which is your entire cluster.
And all users are admin.
But with some features coming
in Kubernetes 1.6 including
role-based authentication,
which we'll cover more in depth
later, we are moving into
a different model where
single-tenant
multiple identities--
there's multiple users,
no really enforcement,
but you still treat the entire
cluster as your boundary.
So as long as you
create multiple clusters
for various projects
or teams that you
don't trust to be on the same
one, then you're totally fine.
And of course, spinning
up clusters in GKE
is super easy, like command line
tools, or you can use the UI.
And then we'll move into a more
cooperative soft multi-tenancy,
where this is more multi-user,
fine-grained authorization
permissions.
It's not entirely
fully hardened,
but it's good enough
for multi-tenancy
inside the same company.
You can control bad actors and
remove them from the cluster.
So what the single
tenant looks like is you
have your entire
cluster as the boundary.
Team 1 and team 2 you trust
to be on the same cluster,
so you put them there.
Otherwise, you'd have a new
cluster for whoever that is.
And so you have
their front-end ops
and their databases running on
the same cluster as each other.
All the nodes have the same
authenticated identity.
All pods have the same
authorization permissions.
And all pods have
network access.
So now I'll pass it back to Alex
to cover identity and access
management.
ALEX MOHR: Thank you, Jess.
So let's talk about identity
and access management.
The first part of this
is authentication--
that is, who are you.
We'll talk in a little
bit about authorization.
What can you do?
So user authentication--
who are you?
If you are the little puppet in
the upper right corner there,
you want to access
a GKE cluster.
One way of doing that
is using bearer tokens,
and another way of doing
that with Container Engine
is that you can use Google
OAuth2 access tokens.
So for example, if you
run that line on the top
after you've authenticated with
Google using GCloud Auth Login,
you can go get credentials
for a given cluster.
And that will configure your
cube control config file such
that it will use
those credentials when
accessing your cluster.
When you then issue your
cube control create command,
passing in some YAML file
that you want to have created,
then what will happen
is your request
will be sent to the GKE
cluster, the API server that's
hosted for you.
And it will receive
that request.
The Google OAuth2 tokens
will be included in there,
and those will then be
forwarded to GCPs IAM service
to verify them.
If that happens,
then, the response
is passed back to the API server
that runs on your cluster,
and you'll then be
authenticated as your identity.
Users are not the only
identity that we care about.
We also have many
system components.
So a Kubernetes cluster is
not just a single thing.
We have the GKE master,
which has controllers and API
servers and many other bits.
But your cluster also
consists of the nodes
that are participating in it.
So the master itself has
a certificate authority,
one CA for the entire cluster.
And the master is then
given certificates
that are signed by that CA.
At the same time, the
nodes in the cluster
are also given node certificates
and keys that are also
signed by that same CA.
And when we create these
nodes on your behalf,
we pass along the details of
what those node certificates
are in the VM metadata
server that these nodes are
running on.
And so then the nodes are able
to fetch that key and that cert
down from the meditative server.
And when they
contact the master,
then you get mutual
authentication.
So the nodes are going to verify
the master cert when they're
talking to it to make sure
that it's really the master
that they expect it to be.
And of course, at the
same time then, the master
can verify that the note is
coming with the cert that
is signed by that
CA, and therefore, it
should be allowed
to join the cluster.
And this is important
to stop nodes
that you do not want to
be part of your cluster
from joining in.
The third pillar of
authentication we have
is for workloads.
So Kubernetes has
support for the things
running inside your cluster
to also have identities.
So maybe you want to have a
cron job-style service that
runs inside your cluster.
And your cron job is going
to do something every hour,
like contact the
API server to create
a particular pod or a
deployment, a replica
set, whatever it wants
to do every hour.
And in that case, the thing
that's running in my cluster
needs to have some
form of mechanism
for identifying itself
to that API server
so it will have permissions
to do what it wants to do.
So there are two parts to this.
On the left, you can see we have
Kubernetes service accounts.
And the way these
are implemented
is that there is a service
account controller that runs,
and it signs any jots
for all of the service
accounts in the system.
So if there is a
service account,
a jot will be created for it.
And those jots then get
stored in the API as secrets.
And so then when you
want to create something
that uses a given
service account,
you can specify for
your pod, please
use specified service account.
And if you don't specify
a service account,
currently the
default is that you
will inherit the namespace's
default service account.
And currently, that namespace's
default service account
usually gives you full
access to the cluster.
So once your pod is running, it
has this access to the secret,
and that secret
will be then mounted
at a known location in
the pod's file system.
And so when you want to make
your request to the API server,
your pods can then
read in that jot.
They can use it
as a bearer token,
and they make that request
to the Kubernetes API server,
and therefore, they
will be authenticated.
And of course, the API server
will allow you to do that.
So again, if you wanted
a cron job or anything
along those lines, maybe you
have a third-party resource
that you want to extend the API
server with, you can do that,
and the service
accounts provide you
a mechanism for doing
that without having
long-lived bearer
credentials that
are outside of this system.
So that's authentication.
Let's talk about authorization.
So given your identity,
or an identity,
what can you do with it?
Today, Kubernetes
supports what's called--
at least called in Kubernetes
ABAC, Attribute-Based Access
Control.
This is really just a very
simple file-based authorization
policy.
If you're running
Kubernetes yourself,
you could configure
it with more details.
But with Container
Engine today, it's
a static file that basically
supports only an admin
identity.
What we'd like to do is offer
people more fine-grained access
control than that.
And so what we've
been doing is working
with some of the
people in the community
to get roles-based
access control, which
is another authorization
mechanism that the Kubernetes
API server will support.
And this is going to allow
for a much fine-grained
authorization.
And you can also
configure it using
the Kubernetes API itself.
So the configuration
mechanism is through the API.
You can create-- we'll
talk a little bit more
about that in a minute-- roles,
and role bindings, and so on.
And so that will
give you full control
to configure the
permissions on your cluster.
So what is the
basic usage of RBAC?
If you look on
the left there, we
have one of the resource
types, and Kubernetes
is a pod that might contain
multiple containers.
And the API server supports
two access mechanisms.
You can call get on
the pod, and maybe you
can call list on a pod.
There are also a whole bunch
more, like create and delete.
But for this simple example,
we'll just focus on list
and get.
And maybe on the
far right up there,
I've got the user in blue.
And I want to be able to
say, hey, this user should
be able to call get on pods.
They should be able to list
the pods in the system.
So how am I going to
do that with RBAC?
The first step is
to create a role.
That's the gray box.
We might create a
pod reader role.
And this basically
says anyone who's
a member of the pod reader
role has that capability.
They can call get on pods.
They can call list on pods,
and life will be good.
So I then need-- the final
piece of this is a role binding.
That's the green box which
says this particular user is
bound to this particular role.
If they have
authenticated themselves
as this particular
user, they have
this role available to them.
And so when the user comes
in, the authorization system
looks and says, OK, you're
alexmohr@google.com.
Look at those roles.
Yes, you do have
the pod reader role.
There's a binding
there between them.
You're trying to call pod.get.
No problem.
Everything succeeds.
So that's the basic usage.
RBAC supports a lot
more complexity,
even in this case
if you said, well,
what if I have nodes as well.
Maybe I want to have, in the
bottom gray box over there,
a node pod reader role.
And that might allow
anyone with that role
to be able to both list pods as
well as get and list on nodes.
And the bindings in this
case also can be extended.
They don't just have
to be plain users.
When your users
are authenticated,
they may come with a set of
groups associated with them.
So if you're authenticated
as mohr@google.com,
and maybe I'm in a group--
Cluster Admins, then
the Cluster Admin group
could be given the
node-pod-reader role.
And it's also not limited just
to users and groups, of course,
but service accounts can
also be part of these things.
And although I don't cover
it in the slides here,
there are many more forms of
this limited to name spaces.
There are cluster
roles and so on.
So it's a pretty decent
authorization system
that gives you a lot of control
if you'd like to use it.
There we go.
So the third pillar of IAM--
we have authentication,
authorization.
The third A is often
referred to as auditing.
So right now, the
cluster API is integrated
with GCP audit logging.
It's currently in beta.
And we currently support
the admin activity form
of this for cluster
modifications.
So if you're going
to create a cluster,
you're going to
upgrade a cluster,
maybe you're going to change
the node pools in a cluster,
you're going to
delete a cluster--
all of those kinds
of admin write
actions are going to be
reflected in an audit log.
And so it's more
or less what you
would expect in simple form.
Alice@example.com
created cluster foo.
A Few lines later,
joe@example.com
deleted the cluster bar.
The details in here include
all of the request information.
They include the response
that we sent back.
They include the identity that
did it, time stamp, cluster IP,
pretty rich set of metadata
about each of these requests.
And those are then sent
to Stack Driver logging
so you can go and use any of the
standard Stack Driver logging
APIs to go look through that.
And of course, the
Google Cloud console
also offers a relatively nice
overview where you can see,
via the UI, what's been
going on in your clusters.
Drill down and so on
is also available.
On the bottom, data access--
this is a very commonly
requested feature.
You're starting to see more and
more of Google Cloud Platform
products include data access.
This would be a log of all of
the read operations being done.
So if somebody is calling a list
node pools or something like
get cluster credentials,
those are the kinds
of things you might expect to
see in the data access logs.
And then finally
in this section,
I wanted to talk
briefly about secrets.
So the previous
section was talking
about authorizing to the
Kubernetes cluster itself.
What if I need to do something
like access a database,
and I need a password
for that database,
a username-password combo?
Or what if I want to make
calls to GitHub and its API?
Maybe I need an access
token in order to do that.
So secrets are a really
nice Kubernetes feature
that allow you to do that.
You can store other static
credentials having nothing
to do with Kubernetes
in those secrets.
You can then use
pods YAML in order
to reference these secrets.
And then when you actually
have these secrets in your pod,
you can access them via a
file mount or an environment
variable.
And you can configure
how they get
exposed to your app that runs.
One of the nice things
about file mounts
is that if you change
your secrets, eventually,
the file mount will also
be updated to do it.
So if you have anything
that is rotating
these things over
time, you can just
continually update the secret.
And then based on
polling intervals
and time to [INAUDIBLE]
on the kubelets, your app,
as long as it's going to
be polling its file mount
on a regular basis, should
pick up those changes
as they happen.
So to give you a brief example
of how that works, on the code
snippets on the
upper right, you can
see that the user name,
in this case, is admin.
And Kubernetes YAML does
base 64 encoding for these,
so that's the YWR string.
Maybe we have a fun password
like 1f2d, et cetera,
and that's also base 64 encoded.
And so in order to specify
the secret, we specify the API
version, the kind, metadata,
give it a name, My Secret,
and then we pass in the data as
a username and password field.
So that's all for IAM for now.
I'm going to pass it
back to Jess, who's
going to talk about
runtime security
and give us a really neat demo.
JESSICA FRAZELLE: Sweet.
Yeah, so runtime security.
Yay.
Containers.
So I just wanted
to briefly cover
the isolation primitives that
make up containers themselves.
So if you don't know already,
containers aren't real things.
When you create
a container, it's
not actually creating this
thing that's called a container.
It's using Linux
primitives that are
namespaces and
cgroups to do this.
Namespaces control
what a process can see,
and cgroups control
what a process can use,
which is like a very clear
distinction between the two.
So as far as namespaces
goes, there's
a bunch that you can use.
You can control what processes
are being seen, mounts,
networks.
UTS is hostname.
IPC is messaging queues.
User namespaces creates an
unprivileged user if you want,
and it will be mapped
to a different user
on your actual host.
And then there's also
a cgroup namespace,
just to confuse everyone,
which controls what
cgroups you can actually see.
As far as cgroups go,
you can control things
like how much memory
will be used, CPU.
You can set a container to
run on a specific CPU set.
So if you want it to run
on 0 or 1, you can do that.
You can control what
devices are being used,
network priority, freezing
processes and threads,
and block I/O, so writing
to disk bandwidth and stuff
like that.
So there's really
a lot of leverage
for you to take the
groundwork here and then
build on top of them with more
hardening aspects of Linux,
which we'll cover now.
So one of these is AppArmor.
And this is a Linux
security module.
This is super helpful
for creating profiles
that will define what
your process wants
to write to so you can set
certain files as read only
without setting the entire mount
as read only, which is insanely
helpful.
Because read only file
systems are great,
but it's very hard to make an
actual application run entirely
that's read only.
You're going to need
to write to something.
So AppArmor is great for that.
You can also deny system
functions, like Mount,
net raw, stuff like that.
It doesn't cover all
system functions.
There's only a small subset.
And we're going to push
towards same defaults.
Docker has the same default
that prevents writing to PROC,
prevents writing to
SYS, all the things
that you should not
be doing regardless,
unless you are running
as a privileged container
and preventing mount.
So this is beta in Kubernetes.
And if you want to use it,
you can do the following
and create an annotation
for your container
that points to this.
And what we're doing here is
using the runtime default,
which will then use
the Docker default
profile for your basic NGINX
container that we have here.
So moving on-- another
one of these is seccomp.
And seccomp gives
you more leverage
over all of the sys calls.
So AppArmor, you could
do, if you like, mount.
But seccomp, you can define
a whitelist or blacklist
of sys calls that your
application is going to use.
So in Docker, there
is a waitlist,
and it has some really
[? sane ?] defaults.
When we were working
on writing it,
I went through all the past
CBEs that were super bad.
And we blocked
things like P trace,
and cloning new
unprivileged namespaces,
which has the highest CVE rate
for breaking out of containers,
things that if your application
is not running as privileged,
you probably don't need anyways.
So for 95% of these
cases, it works out
of the box, which is great.
So this is alpha in Kubernetes.
So if you want to
use this, it's kind
of the same thing as before.
You set the annotation
on your container.
And for this one, we're
using Docker default profile.
So there's a bunch
of other things
that you can set as well.
You can set SELinux context
for labels on volumes
that you have in
your containers.
You can run all your containers
in a pod as a non-root user
or ensure that that's happening.
You can set a read only root
file system, which like I said,
if that's impossible
for your application,
you can actually define
granularly these things
in AppArmor profile instead.
And then you can also
add or drop capabilities
to your containers if
you do not need them.
So what this looks like if
you want to say drop net raw,
which really isn't
all that useful
unless you want to use ping--
you could do this in
the security context
for each container.
And then you can also set
SELinux options and labels,
like I said, on your containers.
You can define that you want
it to be a read only root file
system.
And you can also make
sure that all containers
are running as a non-root user.
So now we're going to
do a demo and switch
to the other computer.
Cool.
OK.
So this will be fun.
So I have a GKE
cluster that I spun up
that's running in alpha mode
so that we can use seccomp,
so you can do the
same if you want.
So we'll just get
another terminal
since this one is dead.
Cool.
Well, that was fun.
So we'll just show that there
are no pods currently running.
Fresh cluster.
Cool.
So now we can have
our way with this.
So I have, first
off, this fun pod
that we're going to
spin up that is cool.
So if we look at
our first pod, it's
going to create five replicas.
If we look here, it's
just a simple app named
Echo, which opens up NGINX.
And NGINX just echoes out a
bunch of header information
and the body of the request.
And it's just a stupid demo app.
Then we have our NGINX configs,
and we're exposing port 80.
And we're not doing anything in
this example with annotations
in seccomp, I just want to show
that we can do things that we
should not be able to do.
So we'll spin this one
up with kubectl create.
So we'll just see that
our pods are running.
And I'll just grab one
of these random ones.
And we can exec in.
And then I'll set the container
as echo, and we'll run bash.
So now we're in.
Hacker voice.
Just kidding.
So I'm going to try
to do something that--
if this was running an NGINX
container, and I was actually--
escaped the
application, if I tried
to like unshare something like
a user namespace to break out,
we would not want
this to happen.
But of course, it works, because
nothing is being blocked.
I'm not running
with any seccomp in.
Kind of blows.
So that's what without seccomp,
If we look at this other one
that I have that actually
does add a seccomp profile,
it's the exact same as
our Echo application.
This one I just named NGINX.
There's five replicas again,
because it's a cluster.
Might as well use it.
And we're setting Docker
Default as our seccomp profile.
So by default, we
know, since I wrote it,
that unshare in a
new user namespace
is going to be blocked.
So let's just verify
that by spinning this up
with another kubectl create.
We'll make sure
that these are up.
And I'll just grab another
one of these randomly,
and we'll exec in.
The container names in
NGINX, and bash again.
So now we'll unshare and
be evil, and it's denied.
So that just basically
verifies that it works,
but that was no fun, basically.
So let's go into a
more real world example
here of trying to
stop a bad person.
So I have another cluster here
that I'm going to switch to.
And on this cluster, it just
so happens that sysadmin
me forgot to upgrade
one of the nodes
after the Dirty
COW vulnerability.
So the interesting
thing about Dirty COW,
if you all didn't know--
when I first heard
about it, what
I'll do with these
types of vulnerabilities
is I'll try and make sure that
the Docker set comp profile
either prevents it or that
we can edit it in such a way
that it will be prevented
for everyone that uses it.
So when I first heard
about Dirty COW,
I was like, crap,
that one is not
actually prevented
by the default.
Because it's using madvise.
It's using literally
nothing bad.
You're just writing to
a read only memory map
and using all the sys cals
that people use daily,
which is hard.
But what I didn't know
was that it needed--
if we look here--
you needed madvise, and you
needed madvise don't need.
So I was thinking to myself
let's just not allow that.
We'll allow
everything of madvise
but not madvise don't need.
So I had this
patch ready to send
like when the vulnerability was
going to be publicly disclosed,
and I was just waiting on it.
And it turns out, actually--
I didn't realize
this before the patch
was made, which was good--
glibc malloc uses madvise don't
need literally all the time.
So that would break almost
all applications by default.
It could not be a
default for anyone.
So this one is very troublesome.
So if sysadmin me is
thinking about my cluster,
and for some reason, we don't
use glibc for any of it,
I could be like, OK, I'm
going to, for the time being,
before I upgrade all the
nodes, and before I realize
if we've been affected
by this or anyone got in,
I'm going to deploy all these
pods with this custom set
comp profile like I showed
that takes madvise don't need.
It allows literally all of
madvise but madvise don't need.
So the order of operations
I'm going to show these
is in a specific order,
because after I pwn the node,
then I can't spin out
more containers on it.
So we're first going
to show blocking it.
So sysadmin me takes
my pod spec here.
And I'm like, I'm going to use
this custom profile that I put.
So it's basically a fork of
the default that adds that.
And I'm going to run
this pop container, which
basically tries to exploit
the Dirty COW vulnerability.
And since I labeled my nodes--
which in real life,
the sysadmin probably
didn't, but I did for the
sake of this demo to make sure
it goes on the bad node--
this is going to run
on the Dirty COW node.
So if we spin this one up--
and now let's get our pods--
cool.
So let's grab this
one and get some logs.
So it tried to pwn the
machine, and it was like,
could not pwn, and now our sad
hacker is sad, which is great.
So we prevented that.
It gave the sysadmin time
to upgrade stuff or assess
if we had been
affected, which is cool.
So another sysadmin comes
along, maybe also me,
and forgets to do this--
forgets to add the
seccomp profile,
forgets to even write
the seccomp profile,
just does not care.
So we have another
one of these where
it's going to run on Dirty COW.
It's going to run the
same exact container pop,
and we're not going
to have any seccomp.
I had to do this one second,
because the node literally
will not respond after this.
So let's delete the old.
And now we'll create the new.
And now let's get our pods.
Cool.
And now we'll grab the
logs from this one.
And so game over.
We could write to this
read only memory map.
We had all these madvise
calls just totally
killing the node itself.
So that's the sad story.
And then also, just
for fun, we can spin up
one of these on the
non-Dirty-COW node.
And I'll show you that
it also doesn't work just
to verify that I'm not
completely fooling you all.
So if we delete the
old, create the new,
we'll grab one of these
again, and our sad hacker
is going to be sad again.
Cool.
So now if we switch
back to the slides,
basically, what we
learned is that you
can run custom profiles.
You can stop bad
things from happening
if you know that they're there.
Usually, the default
Docker profile
would block these things.
There's actually a page that I
wrote in the Docker repo that
has 20-plus vulnerabilities
that were stopped by the default
profile.
But this was just a fun example
for something that was not.
And in other cases, I
would try, like I said,
to modify the profile
without breaking every one,
which in this
case, it cannot be.
So the cool thing about
this is that in GKE,
if you run with opt in for
automatic upgrades for GKE node
pools, this would never
happen, because we control
the OS for all the nodes.
So that's definitely something
you should think about,
because we know
about these things.
We upgrade the nodes for you.
And then you don't
even have to worry--
did I miss a node?
Do I need to do some sort of
custom profile, all of that?
It's pretty great.
And other great features of
the OS that we use are it's
a super minimal base.
Really, everything has
to be running containers.
There's a firewall that
drops all network connections
except for SSH by default.
It's the default node
image for all GKE.
And it's based off Chrome
OS, which has really
been tried and tested as a
great security operating system.
The entire file system
is mounted as read only,
and then certain file
mounts are remounted again.
Like var/lib/docker needs to
be executable and writable,
and your home and var
and a staple partition
mount can hold persisted
state over time.
But that's like literally it.
So super great that GKE
could possibly never
have this happen.
Now I'm going to
pass it back to Alex
to cover the roadmap
for the future.
ALEX MOHR: Thank you, Jess.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
So for the last
section, I'd like
to talk a little bit about the
Kubernetes security roadmap.
Full disclaimer-- this is
an open source project,
and Google Container
Engine inherits whatever
Kubernetes upstream does.
We obviously don't
control it, so these
are somewhat speculative
future directions.
Many people of the
community share these goals,
but there's no guarantee as
to what the future will bring,
of course.
So two parts to this.
First, I'm going
to talk about some
of the more long-term
goals that we have,
the problems that
we'd like to solve.
And then the second
half of this, I'll
talk about what we might expect
to land with Kubernetes 1.6,
1.7, 1.8 over the
next six months.
So we talked a little bit about
security model and stages.
Jess gave us a nice
introduction to single tenant
with multiple
identities, and then
this notion of cooperative
soft multi-tenancy.
What we'd like to
see, though, is
hard multi-tenancy over time.
So this would be where
those security boundaries
between the multiple tenants
of a cluster become much more
strongly enforced.
And I'll talk a little bit
about that in a moment.
We might also want to see things
like better resource isolation.
If I have two containers
running in different processes
on the same machine,
maybe one of them
ends up trashing my L2 cache,
and that causes the other one
to run more slowly.
So there are some
interesting things
in terms of looking at
cycles per instruction
that you might
want to do in terms
of trying to get better
resource isolation
between these different systems.
If you want to think about
what would that maybe look
like, we'll know that we've
met the hard multi-tenancy goal
if you were a provider
and you said, yeah,
I'm happy to have
somebody from Company A
give me some code, whatever
it is, and I'll run it.
And Company B gives me some
other code, and we'll run it,
and they're running on the
same system, the same cluster,
the same nodes.
So if you had hard
multi-tenancy,
it's really about
this hard isolation.
And just because you
don't necessarily
want to run third-party
code for multiple companies,
this might also be useful to
you inside your organization.
Maybe you have multiple
different departments.
Maybe you have multiple teams.
This kind of thing might
also help in that case.
So Jess talked to us about
a cluster and the project
as a security boundary
and gave you this slide
that you saw earlier.
We'd like to change this.
Instead of everything being the
same authenticated identity--
the pods having the
same permissions--
what we'd like to see
instead is something
where the namespace and pod
become much more of a boundary
than they are today.
So this would mean things like
the authorization permissions
could be granted at a
namespace resource level.
So if we look at
the example here,
you might see Team
1 has a namespace,
and they're running
their front ends in red.
Their databases are in yellow.
Maybe there's
another team, Team 2.
They've got their own setup
with front ends and databases,
shown below in blue and green.
And the three nodes here
are hosting the same pods
as before, but now we
have better notions
of separation between them.
In this case, maybe
the nodes have
their individual identities
and per-node permissions.
The pods have identity with
fine-grained permissions.
And we could even maybe think
about how the pods could
have limited network
access to just
whatever is necessary for them.
So let's walk through
these four things
and talk about
the user scenarios
that those would reflect.
So authorization permissions at
the namespace resource level--
so we'd like to move that to
the per namespace per resource
permissions.
Today, everything
has root in cluster.
And that means that
cluster is a boundary.
Instead, what we'd like to do is
take advantage of this security
principle, least privilege.
Should be familiar to
many people in security.
And so the users and
the system should
have the least privilege
possible, also the workloads.
So for example, if one user
of the cluster is Alice,
she would like to be--
we want to make sure
that she can list the
engineering services,
because she's a
member of that team.
But she shouldn't be able to
go and pull down HR profiles,
offer letters, things like that.
Maybe Bob can create things
in the test namespace,
because he's a member
of the testing team,
but he shouldn't be able
to access things in prod
unless he's a member of your
on-call rotation, for example.
Or maybe your
scheduler needs to be
able to know what the
state of the nodes
are and the state of the
pods are in the system,
but there's really no
need for your scheduler
to be able to read
your HTTPS certificate,
so it should not be able
to read the secrets file.
As far as the
nodes go, we'd like
to move them to have
per-node identity
and per-node permissions.
So right now, each of
your nodes can read any
of the secrets in your system.
They can read any of
the pods in the system.
That's OK for today, but
we'd like to really move this
to the least privilege model.
So in this case, some example
might be if I have a node,
it should only be
able to read data
about pods that are
scheduled on that node.
If a pod is running on some
other node in the system,
there's really no need for
it to be able to read that.
Similarly, it should
be able to read secrets
for the things
running on itself,
but it shouldn't be able
to read secrets for things
that it doesn't
need to know about.
And if we get to this point,
then, a compromised node
will not allow any
additional escalation
through the Kubernetes API.
You'll be able to
access things that
happen to live on that node.
But if there are 500 other
nodes in your system,
it won't be able to do
things that reflect on them.
Third, we would like pods
to have their own identity
and permissions.
So as I mentioned now, if you
have a default service account,
the default service account
has full admin capability
on the cluster.
Instead, we would like
to move to a model
where you have to actively
grant workloads permissions.
So if you want to
create your cron job,
it would be reasonable to
say yes, my cron job should
be able to create
pods in the system,
or yes, whatever
my other extension
is that's going to
collect statistics
about the things
running on the system
and create a
dashboard that lets me
do some amount of
visualization, it should also
be able to have these things.
But if it's just your NGINX
running on your cluster,
NGINX really should not be
able to go in and delete
all of your pods, your
deployments, and so on.
Similarly, if you
have namespaces,
if you're running a pod in
one particular namespace,
maybe it can access things
within that localized
namespace, but other namespaces
that are isolated from it
it should not be able
to have access to.
And then fourth,
network policy--
so we'd like to move from all
workloads receiving traffic
from anywhere on the network to
having network control policy--
sorry, network connectivity
controllable by policy.
So this case would be where you
have a front end system, maybe
a back end system.
The front end should be able
to talk to the back ends,
but the front ends
maybe shouldn't
be able to talk to each other.
And maybe your
front end shouldn't
be able to go out to the public
internet and do other things.
And we have some basic support
for network policy right now.
It requires some
external plug-ins,
and so we're going to
iterate on that over time.
I also want to talk a
little bit about a couple
of other features.
So Jess talked about AppArmor
and seccomp and SELinux.
We would like to have support
for more security contexts.
So no new privileges is
a particular Linux flag,
and it carries over between
fork and clone and execve.
And what it does is it
stops new privileges
from being added to a process.
So that way, even if the initial
process can't do something,
it can't then create
some separate process,
give that other process
more permissions,
and then compromise
your system that way.
Another example of the kinds
of things we hear about
is binary verification.
So today, Kubernetes supports
an image policy web hook
so that, for example, every
time a request comes in
to create a pod to
run a container,
it'll take that image and pass
it off to the image policy
service, which can come
back with image allowed
or image denied.
We'd like to expand on that
basic support that's there
and add audit longing for
the image policy check
so that you can have
a full trail of what
images were allowed, who
was trying to create them.
And if you have
support for break glass
to production emergency,
please just run it.
Ignore that it's not signed.
Make sure that that
gets logged as well.
And so that what you can
do forensics afterwards
to figure out what
happened on your cluster.
We've also had some people
talk about binary verification
of Kubernetes and its addons.
So we're shipping all of
these official containers.
Right now, they do not
have any attestation
as to whether they're the right
container or system or not.
And so one of the things
that might come over time
is allowing the
Kubernetes itself
to verify those
containers that it's
running for its controllers,
the kube proxy, the DNS,
the kubelet, and so on,
and make sure that it only
runs fully verified system
components if that's something
you'd like to have happen.
So with that, I'm
going to switch gears
to our last little section
here, Kubernetes 1.6.
I'll talk about the next
releases after that.
So we expect that to be
released in open source
towards the end of March.
Google Container
Engine should start
picking it up and making it
available shortly thereafter.
And then over time,
once we've verified
that it's as stable
as we hope it to be,
we would then do the
automatic upgrades
to that version for
any existing clusters.
So as far as
security model goes,
we'll have a single
tenant with identities
and the beginnings of
soft multi-tenancy.
And pods should not have root
on the cluster by default.
Some of the highlights is that
we're getting this RBAC system.
That's been some
of the main focus
over the last three months--
getting that enabled by
default and giving people
those richer capabilities
to control their system.
We've also been adding
a lot of identities
to the infrastructure
components--
the nodes, the
controllers, and so on.
And many of them have
more limited permissions
than they do with 1.5 and
below, but not all of them.
So Kubernetes is on a
three-month release cycle.
So coming in June 2017,
near the end of that month,
we expect Kubernetes
1.7 to ship.
As far as the security
model for that goes,
it should be a pretty
decent soft multi-tenancy.
And in particular, if you are
able to escape a container,
that escalation should be
limited to just the one
node that it's running on.
So some of the highlights from
a security perspective that we
might expect to
see are finishing
the limiting enforcement
of system components, such
that each particular node can
only do what it wants to do,
what it needs to do.
We expect our audit
logging to get much more
comprehensive to include many
more sources of what's going on
in the cluster, and
possibly also have
capabilities to ship those.
Right now, it's written to
a file on the master itself.
Ship those off to
network endpoints.
And then we also hear a lot
about certificate rotation--
being able to take those
certificates in your system
and rotate them over time.
There's more speculative bits,
things like improved secrets
management.
Right now, the secrets are
written to etcd as a database,
and they're stored
in plain text.
On Container Engine, the disk
itself is encrypted at REST.
So we do have some amount of
encryption at REST for GKE.
But in Kubernetes itself,
they're in plain text in etcd,
so you really need to make
sure that people can't just
read your etcd database.
There's also talk about
runtime isolation improvements.
So you saw how good
seccomp could be.
We'd like to see
that maybe become
the default in Kubernetes and
require people to say no, no, I
have something that is going
to require extra special sys
calls, and I'm going to trust
it to do that, give you this pod
permissions to do
those extra things.
Once we've done all that,
three months later, again,
September 2017, that's when we
expect Kubernetes 1.8 to land.
And at that point,
our security model
is starting what will
probably be a long road
to hard multi-tenancy.
Unclear at this point.
We're not looking forward
quite that far yet.
We're still in the
1.6 shipping phase
and starting to plan for 1.7.
Some of the things
that we might see
are VM-based runtimes via the
container runtime interface.
That would provide an extra
layer of defense in depth.
More binary verification,
potentially that better
resource isolation between
containers that I mentioned.
And then also
large organizations
might like to be able
to specify policy.
Everyone in my org should run
with read only file systems.
You can't create a
pod in my service
that has that flag disabled--
unless, of course, you're
in the special whitelist.
And so to give
you a brief recap,
we talked about four things--
security boundaries, we talked
about identity and access
management, the runtime
security, and Jess's demo,
and then a little
bit of a roadmap
for Kubernetes security.
So with that, I'd like to
invite people to come up
to the two mics for questions.
If anyone wants to chat
privately afterwards--
as privately as you can her--
we'll go outside if
we run over time,
and you can meet
us in the hallway.
[APPLAUSE]